I'm sure there are people who think that it's a post image. I have
n't really thought about imitating it. I made it
with the intention of making Showa flashy.
[Music]
Robot restaurants are the only place in the world.
It is a restaurant where humans collaborate after robots etc. It is a
restaurant where you can eat rice and still see it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] The
name is Osawa Nami I am the president of a robot restaurant
Originally a Japanese salaryman  I'm a little interested in males and females
Ah ah ah
I think that people of that generation were really longing for robots when they were children at that time.
The
customers who are here now are more than cooking overseas
[Music]
[Applause]
Is it cute for foreigners and tourists to receive such things?
I think you're pulling a robot. A male bullet selection team and a team called a life-long sword line. Now, a
human former is a robot
manipulator and a robot rider.
[Music]
[  Applause] I
think the last thing is that a robot that is so big that I have never seen it
comes out, or that a human girl and a male performer and a robot get
together and get excited with the customer
.
ana
[Music] It's
amazing how many ships you have, and when you come
home with a smile, always think that
you're really glad you did it. I'm really happy when you told me that you'll come here when you come to Japan.
[  Music]
Last time I came to Japan Please come to more restaurants
Ah
[Music]